leaking Greer Rusty with fried eggs
[Music]
in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks along
with a knob of butter and season
[Music]
great parboiled potatoes and Greer a
hard swiss cheese with a great nutty
flavor then combine with the softened
leeks
in a pan heat oil and a little butter
spoon in the potato leek and cheese mix
cook gently until golden and crisp
underneath
then slide onto a plate
flip over and return to the pan to
finish cooking
[Music]
finally for the perfect topping fry two
eggs
and place them on top of the rosti
top with fresh tarragon leek and Greer
rosti with fried eggs a simple but
substantial dish that makes the most of
hearty root veg